hi everyone and good morning I'm gonna
be showing you two immune boosting
garlic ferments today so Patrick and I
were talking just before we started
rolling about all different kinds of
things that we do for immune boosting
purposes and we started to write a list
but the list was like this big so rather
than just I tell you all the things we
do I thought that I would just start by
telling you what we've done today what
was what we've done so far um first
thing we did well it started last night
but then I could go on and on but I'll
just stop it last night we went to bed
as early as we could after we'd had
dinner we went to put the goats to bed
he went for a walk and back to stop
hunting skills and then read stories and
then set the fire the mornings so we
tried to go to bed as early as we could
we tried to wake up with the Sun which
we did so we woke up just before dawn so
that's part of it just sort of being in
in the circadian rhythm to align that
with the Sun we set we lit the fire so
that was we chopped the wood we were
thankful for the wood so we started with
some gratefulness we hopped on that
Patrick and I hopped on our bikes we
don't have a car so being on our bikes
and being Hardy to the cold which it is
now here in central Victoria it started
to get very cold with these autumnal
mornings and nights and days to vote on
our bikes down to the local lake we
stripped off and to be naked first thing
out in the world he's a beautiful thing
we went swimming for five to ten minutes
or so and then what freezing and it was
glorious and then we
danced on the deck on the jetty and then
put our clothes back on and then rode
home sat by the fire had tea fed the
chickens for breakfast we had fermented
pancakes with it some way and some from
our cheese making some raw way some and
eggs from our chickens I'm saying I'm a
lot it's early still some a cornmeal
some spelt flour and some buckwheat
flour and then we had it with our honey
and some gifted blackberry jam and some
yogurt and now we're ready to talk about
our some of our ferments that we you're
gonna mention the argument oh yeah we
had an argument which is also part of
immune boosting especially when we wake
up and we're filled with oxytocin and
all the good stuff but also having our
voices heard and being able to express
that in a safe environment is part of
yes feeling confident and feeling loved
and valued even in the more challenging
moments so I love you passionately so we
try to eat something fermented with
every meal and especially this time of
year we really focus on other building
up our medicine chests
what can we grow what can we gather what
can we ferment what can we preserve what
can we prepare that is going to see us
out through the cold and flu season so
my go to my person will go to Patrick
has other ones and I'll talk about that
in a minute but my person will go to is
garlic I really like it's like antiviral
antibiotic properties and I always feel
much better after I've got a tickle I
feeling a little bit vulnerable then I
like to go for garlic but I do find if I
have it in its raw form then I do get a
bit of an upset tummy so I'd like to
ferment it which helps break down
the sugars in it and make it much more
as predigested when it's cemented to
make it much more palatable and easy to
digest and easy to ingest so when we're
sitting by the fire before our argument
we had some are we certain we've peel
some of our homegrown Dalek so ferments
I'm going to show you this morning one
is a sweet one one is a savory one and
they both take about six months to
ferment so we do have some from previous
years so we have very long cold winter
seasons here so even if what we ferment
today is going to last us well into the
cold season so the first one I'm going
to show you is a honey garlic ferment so
just have a regular-sized wrap and some
peels clothes and just going to put some
in a jar like this and maybe a few less
cuz I need a few more for the next one
I'm simply going to you've got some of
our honey from our bees here so I'm
simply going to cover the cloves with
honey and you can put as much as you
want in as long as all of the clothes
are covered with the honey
so we eat try to eat a lot of fermented
foods for a number of reasons the first
one is because they taste really good
the second one is because it preserves
and increases the longevity of the food
that we grow we do it because of the the
now what indigenous people have known
you know in every culture what they've
known for thousands and thousands of
years is that fermented foods are good
for our well-being you know what we know
about the gut brain access and how great
it is to eat fermented foods that it's
good for our gut microbiome but it's
also yeah it's just good for whole body
health so people who eat a lot of
fermented foods I think can attest to
the benefits so I might give this to my
assistant woody would you like to take
the spoon thank you and the gut
regulates the immune system so that's a
big one so as I said in our doing lots
of things with apples video that the
aliens so leek and garlic and onions and
chives are full of prebiotics which is
what the probiotics in our guts ate so
to have this this is the garlic is the
prebiotic and it'll turn into a
probiotic once that starts once the
honey will draw the liquid out of the
garlic and it will become quite runny so
at the moment you can see there that's
gonna take a long time this is raw honey
and yeah just to note about a couple of
things a few step backs a few steps back
that in terms of sterilizing I just use
very hot soapy water I don't need to
sterilize this job because we're
courting life and so if I was preserving
for a long time I sat out or fruit stood
fruit then I were
to sterilize my jars but here I don't
need to sew just hot soapy water when
it's dry then you can put your
ingredients in and in terms of honey
we're very fortunate that we have our
own bees that we harvest honey from but
if you don't have that then if you can
just try to get local honey is really
good because it's got all the properties
that you need for your local bio region
and also the cold extracted is good not
heat extracted okay so we have our
garlic and honey so what I'm gonna do
when I finish up with you guys here is
that I'm gonna make sure the lid is on
really tired I'm gonna stick it in a
cupboard and I'm gonna just turn it on
its lid like this and then tomorrow I'm
going to turn it back this way in the
cupboard and then keep doing this until
the garlic the honey starts to get
really runny and then when it does it's
then you know that it's starting to
ferment and so I'm going to keep doing
that for the next two weeks just keep
turning it because the garlic is going
it's got the it's got oxygen in it and
it's going to want to pop to the top of
the honey and as it starts to ferment
everyday I'm going to so in a couple of
days I'll start doing this so I'm going
to just make sure all the honey is
tripped down and I'm just going to open
the lid like that in fermenting language
that's called burping where you release
the carbon dioxide make sure the lids on
really tight and then stick it back in
the cupboard like that the next day like
that open it up release carbon dioxide
lid back on until it's really really
runny and then I'm just going to keep it
in the cupboard for six months and then
in six month time I've got a couple here
this is from 2018 so two years ago eight
for 2018 and you can see how runny geez
that's not going to take very long for
this honey that we've just made today
to get that runny and also you can see
that it's gone dark and so this was the
same color honey to begin with and you
can see the change in color and
consistency and so now what happens
through the magic of fermentation is
that the honey and the garlic swap
properties so the garlic becomes honey
the honey becomes garlic garlicky
and so now whenever I've got a tickle or
feeling a bit rundown then I will take a
clove and just munch on it and it
doesn't have that sting of a raw clove
of garlic and all the honey that's left
over so this is what I give to woody to
have so he just has that on a tea spoon
if he doesn't want the garlic or I'll
use some of the the honey to braise meat
or what I usually do is just use it in a
salad dressing and here's one that I've
got from last year for 2019 and you can
see that these cloves are a little bit
bigger because they haven't been all of
the the liquid in the garlic hasn't been
drawn out yet
so the reason that we put it in the
cupboard is because it doesn't want
doesn't like to be in the light it's
just a ferment that likes to it's a
private ferment
let's just put it that way like this
lays that what are they called there's
light a lava lamp
a garlic lava lamp okay and when I
finished you I'm also gonna put a label
on it just so I can I know what what
year it is so in two years time you can
say I know remember that day right so
the next cement I'm going to show you is
a fermented garlic paste so I think I'll
show you the end product first so this
is what you can see I've had my fingers
in there so this is a garlic kraut which
is just like a garlic paste so it's two
ingredients garlic and salt and through
the magic of fermentation you can see
the colour has gone from this to this
dark color so I'll just show you how to
make that this is amazing and anything
that you're cooking and you think Oh
what does it kind of need it means
necessary little something garlic rat
these are always your answer definitely
my go-to and I can't make enough of it
put my garlic cloves into my food
processor and I haven't actually tried
to do these with a mortar and pestle
if you give it a go and it
works or doesn't work please let me know
so I'm just gonna guess with the salt a
couple of sprinkles I'd say and when
I've taught this in the past people have
wondered about botulism I've never had
an issue with it so I can't talk to that
I'm going to grind it up make it into a
paste skis nose
[Music]
scoop it into a jar so I recommend using
non-iodized salt for safe implementation
that's best we get our salt from the
pink leg up Needham baller and this was
brought back by our neighbor Bob so
thanks Bob okay so scoop that into my
jar so if you'd like to know a little
bit more about fermentation Patrick
wrote a book a couple of years ago
called reefer minting culture if you'd
like a copy of that as a PDF then just
message us and we'll send you a copy
just looking at the history and as well
as the health benefits of fermentation
in the context of terrain theory which
is really how we live our lives so
making sure we not making sure but just
being open and not fearful to handling
moss and rocks and wood and honey and
soil and just be part of life so again
this will need to be burped I'm just
gonna set this on my fermenting table
you can have the lid screwed on you can
have it not screwed on this is really an
amazing ferment to make and to have your
kids watch you watch part of the process
because it changes colors so profoundly
and so miraculously I've had these um
I've done these ferments before and it's
gone bright blue I've had it go green
the last time I made it with this one
here I filled the jar up so that was a
lot
garlic clove peeling and it lifted the
lid was just sitting there and it lifted
the lid up like this and it went a kind
of green and this was just sitting on it
and then the next day it went back down
again and then slowly over time it went
from this beautiful greeny blue color to
this now brown color it was really
amazing so yeah so this is about a year
old but after six months it was ready
and it takes on this kind of caramely
lemony garlicky salty flavor and the
thing that I use this for most often is
for rubbing on meat that we have on
roast but you can also just have it on
toast having them toast with a bit of
honey is also really delicious yeah okay
I'm just going to show you some other
ferments that I do exactly the same way
as this garlic cement so I've got here's
some grated ginger so you can see how
liquidy this is and at first it took a
long time like the garlic did to turn
over and so yeah this is really
delicious
just to have a teaspoon of it and in
Chinese medicine they call ginger the
messenger because it's so good for our
circulation and it helps all the
different foods and all the different
parts of our blood to get to where it
need the components of our blood to get
to where it needs to go in the body here
I've got a the last little remnants of a
tumeric ginger ferment also just grated
turmeric and then cover with honey the
turmeric one I love ginger that the
turmeric one is probably my favorite
which is where there's not much of a
left at this here is some bloodlines and
that a food co-op cut in and to eat them
by themselves is really like candy
they're really delicious and also
sometimes cut little pieces of it up and
stick it in our fruit loaf or you can
just sort of eat it by yourself it's
just magical this one here is orange
peel chili and black peppercorns and
again highly medicinal and delicious
I've got here that our friend Rosie made
thanks Rosie with our hops it's just the
last little bit of our hops in
last one here this is ginger tumeric
lemon orange peel and peppercorns and
again medicinal and the peel just goes
candied and it was just fresh peel that
we chopped up and put in the honey so
these are just a couple of the natural
flu shot ferments that we make every
year if you have any questions please
send us a message or leave it in the
comments we have been overwhelmed by
people sending us questions and messages
so we will get back to all of you might
just take a while okay Viva